You know when you're minding your own business,
swimming in a lake or ocean and that green
blob touches you and you're NOT DOWN.
That stuff could power your house, your car,
and it could even stop global warming.
Hey there muckrakers, thanks for watching
DNews, I'm Trace.
Algae is plural.
It encompasses a large number of stemless,
rootless, leafless usually monocellular plants
that get energy from photosynthesis.
Algae exist in many colors, red, yellow, purple,
brown, black, and of course, green and blue-green.
All of these absorb light and turn it into
energy.
Algae are a basic food source for both salt
and freshwater animals and birds, their decomposition
releases minerals into the water, and their
mass provides a refuge for small fish and
invertebrates.
If nature loves it so much, why don't humans?
"it's a completely renewable source, and it's
made from sunlight and carbon dioxide and
water.
It's a very sustainable, renewable fuel."
That's Dave Hazleback, founder of Global Algae
Innovations.
He thinks these tiny plants can be way more
valuable than they are already.
Steve Woods is a mechanical engineer and he
works with Dave, turning algae into fuel for
cars, trucks, and airplanes….
The ones that we deal with are micro algae,
so it's a little single-cell and you could
start with just a single cell and grow it
all the way out and just have it multiply
and everything, just growing plants.
You just feed them what they need, carbon,
hydrogen and nitrogen and stuff.
They just grow and they multiply like crazy.
For some DNews episodes that's a bad thing,
but for this?
You WANT it to multiply.
Eventually, it will fill up these pools they
call raceways, and Steve will pull them out,
drain the water, and dry it all out.
That’s actually really hard by the way.
The dry algae can be turned into food for
animals (or people), but…
When you feed them certain things or stress
them in certain ways they can produce oils
and different things that are beneficial for
nutraceuticals and pharmaceuticals stuff and
everything, so it's cool.
There are over 100,000 different types of
algae, and they store energy in the form of
oil.
...the oil can be easily converted into drop-in
fuels which means it can be converted into
gasoline, diesel, and jet that can be used
directly in current engines.
You don't need any special modifications or
anything to run an algae biofuel.
The fuel that we're producing is equivalent,
is exactly the same in terms of performance
as gasoline or diesel or jet.
Renewable diesel actually performs better
than petroleum-based diesels.
Biofuels, like these, are energy sources that
come from living matter.
They stand apart from fossil fuels (which,
by the way, also come from living matter)
because biofuels are made now, and not over
millions of years.
You've probably heard of ethanol, a fuel made
from corn; it's easy to make with the industry
we already have, but it's not the best biofuel…
It takes a lot of time to grow a whole field
of corn, but to grow-out a lot of algae is
a lot faster and it's just a plant.
On top of that, the U.S. Department of Energy
believes algae could be 10 or 100 times more
productive than other bioenergies!
Biofuels aren't new; Henry Ford's Model-T
was designed to run on ethanol, but ethanol
only packs half the punch of gasoline.
As people recognize the issues with global
warming and climate change, biofuel technology
has only gotten better.
Fossil fuels crelease carbon that was trapped
inside of our planet for millions of years,
but because biofuels are plants...
"... you're capturing the carbon dioxide,
so it's not being released and that's part
of it.
// You can grow algae 40 times more algae
per acre than you can with terrestrial crops
and as a result you don't have all the deforestation.
On top of that, these biofuel farmers only
need the oil.
Algae can be used for industrial applications
and in food and drugs.
The algae even contains omega-3 and omega-6
fatty acids that are required for healthy
humans, but difficult to find in the food
chain.
Algae are pretty incredible little organisms,
but this process isn't perfect yet.
In the past, biofuel has been very expensive.
Though, according to Dave, they're down to
two or three dollars a gallon to make it now,
but they still can't make enough to compete
with larger petrogas companies.
Hopefully, someday in the future, algae raceways
could replace oil fields, and gas stations
will pump out biofuel!
Algae could also stop global warming in it's
tracks!
Seeker Stories got to actually GO to the plant
in Hawaii where this biofuel is made, they
learned about how algae plants plus power
plants equal a healthier Earth.
Check
it out here.
Would you put algae in your tank?
How about in your mouth?
I mean t is a food source after all!
Let us know in the comments, make sure you
subscribe for more DNews and thanks for watching.